what is the
wildest [ __ ] because you know i remember
when you had the party with trouble
in atlanta and there was the infamous
cucumber party which seemed to have
kicked off a trend of a lot of women
sucking in [ __ ] cucumbers across this
entire country
but that that was the first time i had
saw it but what is the craziest [ __ ]
booze that you have ever seen a female
do with your own eyes when it comes to
just the nasty [ __ ] because i feel like
you've probably seen it all
i don't really know is change turn
normal
it's just normalized now [ __ ] go down
and suck a dick while we were right
there in vip
it's just how i go down you know we're
going to cover him up we're going to
give him blocking michelle
you know they know they know like we we
with that [ __ ] like
we're having a good time so just a girl
sucking dick in vip in the middle of the
club that's
kind of yeah that's probably dick jacked
off a lot too
so you get a hand job yeah we get hand
jobs all in the club i might lay behind
my [ __ ]
yeah beat this [ __ ] right quick
[Music]
i got a [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna lay behind
a big figure big feet go put that big
wall up
he go cover it hey so let me ask you
something is it hard for you to like
finish in a club
nah you just gotta use it you gotta
focus bro you gotta like because i feel
like if i'm in the club and there's all
these the homies all right i'm gonna get
hit
i'm gonna get here in the club that is
going to be already damn it up
okay okay cause i feel like it would be
hard for me to get all the way
to that point if i got out like you know
i don't know a rookie with doing it in
the club
fair enough that's why you're gonna be
he said i've been i've been getting it
in a club for a minute not really just
you know just a little head sometimes
you're gonna get a
you know celebrities get off your head
like you know you get offered head a lot